[Music]
hi my name is max and today we want to
show you the universal intensity model
and how by following a strict set of
behaviors you can be that perfect
communicator
max max I hate you around but I don't
think you're being very odd that's right
now there is not one strict definition
of authenticity there is no one
universal set of visual or vocal or
verbal cues in order to be your best
self in any and all situations instead
today we are going to tell you how to be
your authentic self but how to adapt it
for different contexts we're going to
start by reiterating the importance of
first impressions but as you grow into
new roles and responsibilities you want
to be able to adapt your persona as the
situation demands finally and maybe most
importantly we've discussed how to stay
authentic as you move across culture and
context now as much as we like Max and
his unique qualities this is not a story
that can be told by one voice we have
four unique voices in this group we are
all going to tell the same story you can
be authentic while adapting for each and
every situation you are in so
the first step to be authentic is the
first impression why because there is no
second chance to cause an authentic
first impression as we have here today
first impression take a relevant role
when we want to give a talk because
people are going to judge so when you
face the audience the audience is going
to love you for the way as you dress the
way as you speak even the way as you
breath so if we're talking about a
twenty City can we train the first
impression can we work on that in going
to the first impression be authentic we
think no but dig Morgan in a important
article that's called how leaders become
authentic give us a very good tips even
though there are people that never going
to learn how to be authentic look that
picture in that handshake do you think
there is authenticity no why what
because the non verbal method is more
important in the first impression that
is spoken message people understand and
read then the nonverbal method better
and faster that the word that they are
going to say so yes to speak louder than
world
so what said Nick Morgan me Morgan said
that we had to work in four different
state but focusing in the first
impression we want to focus to be open
what is this
of be open imagine given a speaker or
given a talk and you are in an audience
in a closed position people are going to
see you as a threaten that you have fear
so what he told us what he teach us is
trying to magic that you are giving your
presentation to someone with whom you're
completely relaxed for example your
mother of clothes a friend but when you
imagine that situation not only imagine
the mental picture also how do you feel
then the next time that you're going to
face the audience put that feeling that
mental picture innocent remember
nonverbal message is going to be faster
than the verbal message so you've made a
great first impression and people
perceive you as authentic so where do
you go from here I want to introduce you
to the concept of adaptive authenticity
which of first glance
sounds a bit oxymoronic doesn't it
doesn't being authentic mean that
there's this one view of what's true but
the word adaptive that means that
there's a more fluid version associated
with what authenticity can be the
reality is that whenever we put
ourselves in uncomfortable situations it
can make us feel like an imposter at
first for example when we try a new
communication style like using grand
gestures or making eye contact for at
least four seconds but no more than
seven so what does this do to us what
we're actually end up doing is using
authenticity as an excuse for us not to
take risks and not to step outside of
our comfort zone I want to introduce you
to the adaptive authenticity journal
journey journey at the beginning my
behaviors that feel unnatural and often
superficial things that are outside of
your comfort zone but eventually those
things move into a place where they feel
genuine spontaneous and
actually part of authentically you it's
a short comment that shows where you can
start with your comfort zone or even
your authenticity zone so we start there
her safe place we go out and try a new
communication style or leadership style
let's say we go do that thing we come
back and we come back to our zone but if
you observe it's just a little bit
larger than it was before and that
represents the space of how we've
expanded our range of what is authentic
to us here's what it looks like in
practice you start at this core this
core authentic you which doesn't change
it remains largely the same but through
time practice and courage you expand it
outwards and give yourself a greater
toolset for which you can use so some
people have a very strict view on what
rigid authenticity looks like there's a
few push backs people usually give us
they'll say ok well I always want to be
true to myself so I can't really change
what authenticity is we'd respond to
that by saying what self are you
referring to is this your professional
self your personal self the self you
have in your head and also how do you
account for the fact that there's a lot
of uncertainty in your future and what
yourself will become a second pushback
is people want to maintain a strict
coherence between what they say and do
versus what they feel and despite what
touchy-feely tells us there are
circumstances in this world we don't
want to exactly show what we're feeling
in all cases let's say we're in a
leadership position for the first time
leading a thousand people and we feel
nauseous and terrified you'll probably
lose credibility if you're completely
open in that situation with your team
finally it's important to maintain
values based choices but also remember
that values too should be reconsidered
and reevaluated and you're allowed to
add values into your life so I want to
leave you with three tips to expand your
authenticity zone first of all learn
from diverse mentors new people will
power your life with new communication
styles and leadership styles from whom
you can borrow things that inspire
you so give yourself permission to take
the things you like and then build your
own hybrid of what is authentic with you
second of all consistently work on being
better see constructive feedback and set
learning goals for yourself perhaps even
take a course like strategic
communications or do a low-key note and
finally don't stick to your one story
too often we get grounded in what the
version of ourself is but first of all
our stories is growing by one day every
single day and second our perspectives
changing as well which can help us
review our past in a different way and
retell our story over time so max has
told you how to expand your idea of
authenticity internally but what about
times when your external circumstances
dictate what authenticity means culture
changes what authenticity means a huge
part of authenticity depends on how you
connect with the audience and audience
in different cultures have different
expectations two weeks ago I reunited
with my middle school good friend who
happens to be doing an MBA in the UCLA
program so I saw him and it's been 12
years so we're a little bit on edge you
know we start speaking in English
because that's what we're more
comfortable with nowadays and we start
sharing about our careers our future
plans our recent moves and I felt really
empowered I was like wow I feel very
I feel very different and so after 15
minutes we decide that okay we're gonna
sort of switch to Vietnamese because now
we've established that connection and
all of a sudden I feel myself just
changing my body started shrinking you
know my boys got a lot softer and I
started getting really frustrated about
this new self that for some reason is
coming back to me and this is my 15 year
old self when I knew him
school in fact what I was reacting to
was different expectations and the
associated culture that comes with the
language in which we were speaking in
there's studies that actually show this
phenomenon professor a professor of
Baruch College little study and asked my
lingua Hispanic American women to judge
what some women in an ad come across as
in two different versions one in English
and the other one in Spanish in the span
of six months in English the woman were
perceived as dependent on the family
very traditional while six months later
the same ad has very different
perspectives from the subjects of the
study where they think that this woman
actually come across as very extroverted
and very independent so what should you
draw from that there are different
pillars for verbal vocal and visual in
which all the expectations might change
in one culture of vulnerability could
mean over sharing in another culture
speech volume being loud and clear in
English might actually mean obnoxious in
Vietnamese or your body language and
your speaking space being very open
could actually taking up a lot of space
could mean arrogance in another culture
so the takeaway is really just learn
your surrounding learn the context if
you're presenting to people in a
different culture or a different
language
make sure to adapt and even though
you're sticking to your version of
yourself make sure what the audience is
you know what the audience is expecting
of you and don't be an obnoxious
American
all right before we close that and we
want to leave you guys with a few things
so first Shakir says hips don't lie
first impressions matter and so make
sure your visual cues are all on point
this is going to it's okay to adapt what
is authentic to you and your leadership
persona as you change and grow in fact
you should probably do this because over
the course of your career you're going
to move around this big wide world of
ours it's important to be an effective
leader in multiple cultural contexts
finally and maybe most importantly you
don't need to be like max you have your
own unique voice and embrace it tell
your story thank you
[Music]